Baby's Day Out you might think of that
movie as a silly movie about babies it
is it's also a stunning technical
achievement from ilm with some
incredible shots
[Music]
that baby just dropped Serena's never
seen dark city maybe you haven't either
but it's got some mind-bending VFX and a
Vibe unlike any other movie what I'm
curious about though is how they
actually got that middle table element
we are going to revisit the mask because
there are even more incredible shots
that we haven't talked about and are
going to explore that looks amazing what
the heck what year did this come out 94.
wow we're also gonna be looking at some
old school visual effects that are gonna
stump us we gotta figure out how they're
done it's a mystery motion control it's
before it existed
let's get to it
[Music]
let the tuning come in what movie is
this darks have you ever heard have you
seen dark city I have no idea what this
is it is the freakiest movie ever made
wait a minute
was that a morph yeah that was bizarre
looking it was like a building morph so
everybody passes out and they go and
they like change the city and they
change people's memories it's gonna
drown in his milk
foreign
[Music]
what in the world is going on
good Lord so cool
well that was a cool shot what I think
is going on here is that there's two
tables and they're separated and the
actors and the table are being pulled
outwards from the center of frame then
once they finish that camera move then
they go in and actually put the middle
table there with all the dinner plates
and glasses and whatnot there for the
final shot so now that we have the
elements of those things in place the
artist could then go through and like
magically make them appear as the table
is stretching they're still separated
from it but they land in their final
placement yeah you can see the
perspective shift on the little
candelabras there you can see how
they're kind of going outwards so yeah
it's two real elements there and you can
actually see the blend line between the
middle part of the table and the two
real practical side tables you can see
at the top of that there's just a slight
misalignment at the top and there's also
some weird shading going on underneath
Kiefer Sutherland's hand as the the
table is moving oh yeah Shadow going on
there and they forgot that they animated
it's there and then you lose
that's funny what I'm curious about
though is how they actually got that
middle table element did they finish the
camera move and then bring in a brand
new table for the entire thing and they
only just use that middle part how I
would have done it is I would have just
taken out the entire table and just made
sure that the new full-length table
matched up as perfectly as I could and
put the full tablecloth on it but I
would only use that middle part yeah I
would have a fully dressed table off the
side cut actors leave don't move the
camera don't change the lights there you
go oh yeah they do have the phone yeah
we would have waited one more second
just watch the next shot but the one
really cool thing about that is that
they don't have to do a morph in the
middle of the table which would have
probably been really problematic for
this shot a morph is just one image
being warped into a new position and
then another eventual image it
transitions to starting warped and
moving to its neutral position and then
a Crossfade between the two yeah like
the clearest just raw morph that we're
seeing here is basically on that mantle
fireplace area where we're seeing the
actual wallpaper shrink and grow to
start matching the proportions of its
next object and then for the additional
items that are on there they're
isolating those that lamp that's
disappearing there's the clock that's
disappearing and then there's a bunch of
other things that are starting to come
into appearance and those are just being
animated into the shot through a mask
essentially so it's like you cut out the
object and then reveal it on during that
transition so it's a layer on top of the
morph as well we did talk with John
Burton the man who did one of the most
famous warp shots in history the
Terminator 2 orb it's an amazing episode
like with one of the greats in the
industry so yeah you should check that
out if you haven't seen it all this
holds up all this will hold up forever
this movie was executed in a way where
all the effects are as good as they have
to be and need to be and you don't need
to be any better even though the morphs
you know you look at them and go like oh
they're like morphing stuff it's like
well it is also stuff transmutating from
nothingness so it's like well what else
would it look like yeah do you need a
three million particle simulation to
sell that or does this little Wibble
warble job all right I'd like some
suggestions please can you tell me a
scene that you saw from a movie when
you're a kid that scared the crap out of
you we're gonna do some VFX reacts to
that yeah why did it scare you why is it
so spooky
[Music]
let's lighten it up Baby's Day Out Oh
wait we're actually watching babies yeah
from start to finish
yes oh
that's a green screen shot wait
[Music]
that baby just dropped like it's pretty
wild the shots they're getting with this
little baby yeah like the top down
shot's a green screen shot it's a really
well for blue screen wait is it though
you can tell by the shadow being just a
solid cut out that doesn't have
perspective also if you look at the
shadow of the board on the ground it's a
crisp Shadow and the baby Shadow is soft
so can I blow your mind Nico
it's a robot baby really
it's a robot no they have multiple baby
wow toys amazing wow dude that is so
articulate though some producer was like
I have this goofy script about a baby
I'm gonna spend millions of dollars I'm
gonna hire grown people adults to make
baby puppets yeah and here's the thing
like there's a lot of things you take
for granted if you have an actor who
does a stunt you get a stunt double but
if you have a baby who needs to do a
stunt it's not like you can get a stunt
baby you know and at the time you know
like what are your options it's CGI or
it's a dummy or an animatronic a robo
baby up there
so there's a lot of comps in this scene
yeah that's a good comment you don't say
they're pretty good comps though oh man
this Baby's Day looks so good
oh man dude this baby
dude the freaking sliding baby
that shot is weird that's a great oh it
was a dog
it's pretty clear it's pretty clear that
he's adult very clear that it's a doll
in the dog she has an expression do you
see it start to smile no it's an
animatronic doll look at adult yeah
okay good
but yeah like
man like these comp shots are fantastic
they are all that stuff looks so good
what is that hey wait yeah let's look at
that background shot again is that just
a painting so first off that element of
the guy standing on the ledge is
isolated and placed there yep that's not
part of a set that's him filmed from the
right angle and then boom he's put there
so it's probably a model those cars are
definitely not real cars either yeah
it's got that weird like unreality to it
yeah so I think the building is
definitely a model because we're looking
up at it in the very next shot so it
makes sense to have a big physical model
of this thing so that you can have
different camera moves I don't know if
you'd make a model for everything in
that shot just like from the sheer
practicality standpoint here's my guess
the ground of the construction site and
the roadway that is a model but the
building's off to the left and right
there is actually just a perspective
trick and it's just painted on a flat
surface
could be right yeah sounds looks sounds
about right to me and then obviously the
whole freaking I-beam with the people
hanging from it is a separately filmed
comp on a stage and then of course they
have the the twin real life set it's
pretty great uh yeah it's very
convincing it looks like those people
might be comped but it also kind of
looks like they might not be correct
while they're reacting to babies day out
you guys are going to join me on
Jordan's day out Nick just texted me
from behind camera and he said the guys
need a boost I need some energy drinks
to keep going keep reacting in order to
get out there I gotta face these dirty
streets but luckily I have on Bessie's
which is awesome today's sponsor come on
so if you didn't know Bessie is a
lightweight comfortable and versatile
shoe that is redefining what waterproof
looks and feels like there's a bunch of
different styles that you can choose
from whether you just say walking around
downtown also if you're going on a hike
and every single bestie slips on and off
super easily they have this four-way
stretch it's like Second Skin for your
feet
Dusty actually
[Music]
around here
they're made with this diametex
technology and this keeps your feet
breathing all day waterproof and they
keep your feet cool in the summer and
warm in the winter if you're outside and
you make a messy on your Bessie you can
go back inside rinse them off and then
go right back out they're super easy to
clean because they're 100 waterproof
acquired okay mission accomplished but
before I go in there I need to watch off
my shoes because they are dirty
luckily I can clean these right off let
me grab my water from my knapsack if you
want to experience the waterproof
comfort of Bessie shoes head over to
bessie.com quarter crew and you can get
your own pair for 15 off using our
discount code Corridor crew Link in the
description below all right yes you're
messy it is worth pointing out that this
is an ilm based movie with John null the
father of Photoshop being the VFX
supervisor on this movie so it's
acceptable to say that there's some very
clever visual trickery going on here
anyways yeah Baby's Day Out it's kind of
funny how few shots of the baby are in
this movie and of all the shots of the
baby in the movie how many of them are
the real baby versus the dolls and
robots
do that robot baby is that a robot nah
this is a baby
I don't suppose you have a sister
only a twin sister a twin sister all
right we're about to look at the ending
shot from the Palm Beach story which
came out in 1942. this is the topaziri
special he mentioned this online and I'm
totally going to uh share that because I
thought this was fascinating the context
is that there are two sets of twins that
are getting married but there's only one
set of actors for each of those twins so
they're having to do some cloning
effects now this is 1942 before motion
control is a thing so let's look at this
shot
wow
so the two actors on the left are the
same as the two actors on the right kind
of almost far right
and now look at this
some crazy text titles overlaid on this
whoa whoa how can I possibly do that I
know that was cool that was trippy
Somebody went hard on the end of this
movie yeah right that's sweet so go back
you can see the scene you see the seam
but it still asks the question how could
they pull this off look at that oh all
right so we see a seam there's obviously
some sort of duplicated shot going on
here some sort of track mat but the
camera is moving yeah I hope they do
that without motion control because they
don't have motion control because we
haven't gone to the Moon yet
the moon technology was used probably
think about it think about it well
motion control shots came after the moon
landing yeah
[Music]
well okay point being though we know
that this is not a motion control shot
as we know of it in its modern form but
there are two camera moves happening
here but
that's the question how did they pull
this off is that a mirror do you know
the answer no one knows the answer to
this oh that's the crazy thing there is
no documentation on how this was done
maybe there was motion control now how
would they have done that for motion
control to work you need a lot of data
to basically control that speed because
it's not just the fact that it's moving
it's not just about hitting a consistent
speed it's the whole point that like the
shot starts still and then gradually
that's exactly yeah and then gradually
slows down you could do it with like a
weird weight and pulley system you know
like a clock imagine like a grandfather
clock on how it keeps them yeah so if
you could actually potentially do a
similar thing but attach it to a camera
rig where you basically have it on a
track and basically you're just like all
right here we go we take the shot and
you let go and wait holds up and goes
down and as it reaches the bottom it
naturally slows itself so you could you
could basically have like a straight up
mechanical motion control because clocks
existed at this point in time
and then it goes to like these really
dope floating text elements here and I'm
pretty certain I know exactly how this
entire closing shot was made but I'm
very curious to hear what your guys's
guesses are well first off we've got a
back play that's projected then we have
a miniature set there but for the
floating text it reminds me of something
that would be like on glass but
potentially done with multiple passes
but once again if it's multiple passes
then we're back to motion control I'm
pretty sure I know exactly how this was
done what do you think obviously the
text is on some sort of pane of glass
that first one might be static and the
camera starts basically right up against
that glass looking through that small
little set there in the projection
screen and then the camera starts
pulling back and now we can see the text
is out of focus because it's too close
to the lens yeah and you see the shadows
and stuff too the camera and the
equipment passing but notice how then
there's a secondary set of text that
also comes out of focus and what I think
is that that second pane of glass is
also on the Dolly track and it's moving
with the camera from the beginning of
the shot it's right up against the
camera and it's moving with the camera
and at a certain point that glass stops
moving and the camera keeps going you're
right you are right that is smart it's
cool it looks really nice filming
elements on glass really sweet yeah I
think we've only done that once and that
was for the gravity gun video yeah for
the floating floating Coke bottle yeah
which turns out based on that cool shot
in 2001. before we get to this next clip
I have a little thing I have to mention
it's just between you and me come on are
you listening
thank you
[Music]
now we briefly looked at the mask in the
really early days of the fxr's react
because we're looking at cartoon smears
and how they replicated them in 3D but
this whole movie is a masterpiece
straight up I've watched it again
recently it's just it is incredibly well
made
The Mask tracked to his head that's
distorting and moving and reacting to
the lightning that's going on it's very
well done
up
I've never understood how they got that
crazy spinning effect done well I
actually did a bunch of research and
I'll tell you oh sick you have a whole
bunch of things on set coordinated to
like fall over and get blown around so
they kind of you know they already have
anything planned out or he's gonna do
this do this thing this effect of him
spinning is basically just they got
pictures of Jim Carrey on like a
turntable and projected it onto geometry
on the inside of this tornado and the
outside is basically just donuts like
colored Donuts that are spinning around
really fast it just all has a bunch of
motion blur looks really good yeah they
discovered that like they needed a solid
core to like map it makes sense and like
there's like glimpses of his face in
there and stuff like that yeah I saw a
skeleton in there too that's a weird
little Easter egg but it's the hand of
the animator that's like you know giving
it the wobbles and the warps and like
the offsets like everything is
meticulously frame by frame you know
animated
[Music]
I like how he has big teeth yeah I was
just noticing that too like these days
this is a face people would do in CG
it's incredible the amount of like
expression and range Jim Carrey gets
from prosthetic makeup
[Music]
dude that CG clock that looks amazing
what the heck what year did this come
out 94.
94. wow what a year famous day I came on
the same year this is also ilm yeah
whoa I just realized the Mallet he just
pulled out he's holding a real stick but
the end of the Mallet is CG tracking
yeah special effects real holes being
made yeah now the head of that hammer is
real
what a wacky movie like Jim Carrey's
decision to be like with his mouth there
it's like that's something like an
animator would usually do but to have
the actor actually get to do it on set
it's great because like yeah like doing
the eyeballs in the tongue not that hard
actually yeah you have to track it by
hand a little bit but like it's real
basic animation of course back then no
one had never done it before there's no
tutorials for it there's no
documentation yeah YouTube Just people
in a void going like can we invent tools
to do this can we make this up
those little uh ground cracks
wait
did a fully CG oh man that projection
projection mapping is like the go-to for
everything in the 90s when it comes to
CGI just film it for real then shoot it
onto a 3D model and then you don't have
to render anything honestly it's still
kind of the way to go today too even the
shot of him falling down with the glass
is actually kind of interesting look at
that so what's real there is anything
happening there for real or is he
composite I think the glass is an
element and he's an element yeah it hits
the tree there yep you're right yes it's
probably all practicals at the very end
where it transitions to this this double
that animates into camera yeah because
he goes right up to the lens they
replace his face for sure maybe the
whole body there as he gets super close
yeah this just goes to show that like as
long as like the lighting is very
intentional and strong you know it's got
to have a strong sort of vibe to it it
works because obviously like it's it's
not like they got Global illumination or
anything on these renders and yet the
renders kind of hold up they still look
good mask great visual effects deftly
executed what a treat of a movie
definitely watch it if you've never seen
it oh yeah by the way if you're sad that
this episode's already over well guess
what this episode's even longer with an
extended version on quarterdigital.com
you can sign up now and get a free
two-week trial you can see red and see
the ending of dark city so you can see
the ending of dark city yeah that was
nuts one of the many endings yeah up is
that why people believe in Flat Earth
today
that's probably where all the renderings
come from
foreign